[Applaudissements]
elle a chaud de ma tenue que se
passe-t-il que se passe-t-il si je suis
dans un état là c'est ma tenue c'est ma
tenue
je sais pas si j'ai le droit
les gars j'ai ramené de la truite là
pour les amateurs
est-ce que pour une fois nous on a le
droit de vous demander d'aller vous
changer
pour moi il y en a trois qui sont
pas du tout qui sont au-dessus de la
mode
le reste
les chéris on pense que voilà on vous
aime beaucoup
je pensais pas la peine donc on va
démarrer par Kelly vedové alors la tenue
est extraordinaire j'ai rien à dire la
coupe j'en mets le collier si vous
voulez la tenue mais vraiment au niveau
de spons j'ai vraiment pas
tu peux venir parce que je vais vous
dire ça n'est pas mon idée
ça n'est pas mon idée
alors au départ j'avais mis des baskets
montantes noires
et après c'est un petit choix de
dernière minute je pense que ça ce
serait mieux donc ce que je vous propose
il a dit grave on va aller chercher j'ai
dit grave il a raison
qu'il a lui comment ce serait bien dans
votre style
alors que là il y a un truc assumer
la chaussette haute qui dégueule sur le
mollet j'ai vu la chaussette haute qui
dégueule sur le mollet
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable
il y a encore la fin du monde
c'est une vraie proposition c'est une
vraie proposition proposition et tout
est dans les grolles les grottes sont
fantastiques
je mets ces chaussures avec le petit
logo de la chaussette à peine
dévoilerons
beaucoup par là
alors dis-moi
ce que Kelly la tenue est fantastique
j'adore la veste le short canon les
chaussures un peu basses comme ça avec
une ah c'est pas est-ce que tu aurais
mis on dirait que vous avez mis quelque
chose pour aller chercher les poubelles
et
[Applaudissements]
Messi c'est le public qui décide
toujours qui trouve ma tenue dégueulasse
levez-vous
avez-vous levez-vous
alors il y a ce côté moi ça va ce côté
là n'aime pas du tout petit à petit
[Rires]
merci merci
[Applaudissements]
il y a des gens qui se lèvent
[Rires]
c'est magnifique
[Applaudissements]
j'adore l'ensemble
et le collier c'est quelque chose
Valentin est exceptionnel
j'étais pressé il m'a pas vu partir
il m'a donné les chaussures il m'a pas
vu partir voilà après voilà chacun
tirera les conclusions bien entendu il
veut
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on verra même plus après
rarement ici parce que je ne veux pas me
mélanger
aux autres donc voilà mais si vous posez
la question
moi j'adore les bottines Baba c'est ma
mère
elle aime l'ensemble elle est dans la
mode elle est dans la mode elle est dans
la mode mais si vous posez la question
c'est que vous n'êtes pas très sûr de
vous ah moi je suis toujours sûr de moi
alors tu vois c'est ce que tu me connais
malin je suis sûr de moi
mais ça le dérange pas en soirée moi là
il y a pas de réseau
[Rires]